[MUSIC PLAYING]
SEBASTIAN KRIESE: You
have to make sure that you
work on the best possible game.
Don't waste your time on
something you don't believe in.
Work on the stuff that
matters and make sure
that you have the vision right.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Wooga is a mobile game
developer based in Berlin.
At our headquarters here, we
have more than 250 employees.
We produce high
quality mobile games
that are being played by
more than 50 million players
every month.
The most popular games are
Diamond Dash, Jelly Splash,
and Agent Alice.
Agent Alice is a
hidden object game.
Launched on February 26th, Agent
Alice got 9 million to date.
Six of them coming from
Google Play and Android only.
We release a new episode
every single week
to keep players engaged
and to keep them
active over a very long time.
Google Play allows us
to run fast iterations
for Agent Alice.
All new features and
updates are being
developed for invite
first before they
come to other platforms.
PAL TAMAS FEHER: Our
business is very fast.
So our development approach
has to be also very fast.
Our developer cycle is
usually one to two weeks.
And this [INAUDIBLE] in
Google Play is a clear winner.
We can just publish and
release our games within hours.
This is what we really do love.
SEBASTIAN KRIESE: Already in
the prototyping and concepting
phase, we can leverage the beta
testing feature on Google Play.
The staged rollout helps us
to release a new feature only
to a tiny set of users to make
sure that everything is stable
and that it's actually
perceived well.
The combination of Google
Play and Google Analytics
enables us to understand
our users even better.
Looking into the
different KPIs, we
can make sure that
we understand where
our users are coming from.
Tracking different steps during
the first time user experience
helps us to understand when
the user is potentially
leaving the game.
Whenever that happens, we
can iterate extremely fast
and make sure that we optimize
those points to make sure
that users stay even
longer in our games.
We have to make
sure that the image
quality is the best possible
on whatever screen you look.
However, we usually don't
want to put huge graphics that
are being displayed on a
tablet into a game that
is being played on a phone.
This is the reason why
we love the multi APK
feature of Google Play.
It helps us to bundle
our games to make sure
that the file size is
as small as possible
for the individual users.
PAL TAMAS FEHER: Use
the full potential
of the fast iterations and make
your game with every iterations
better and better.
[MUSIC PLAYING]